well this is a tough one uh new at six
o'clock the animal foundation is simply
running out of room at the shelter
officials have taken and listened to
this
425 animals in four days they're calling
this a critical space crisis so they're
asking anybody to please step up to
volunteer or to adopt some of these pets
to buy them some more time the
foundation says they may have to make
some very difficult decisions if they
endude and indeed do run out of room
they're looking for at least a hundred
dogs to be fostered if you can help over
this long holiday weekend there's more
information or even into next week you
can do that on our website at
8newsnow.com